I have to start with the most important
question what is it like getting a
paycheck from Disney to helm Lion King
and work on Star Wars stuff and Star
Wars and by the way Marvel became Disney
while I was working there on Iron Man 2
so I'm I keep getting pulled deeper into
the orbit of Disney but fortunately the
stuff that Disney is working on is the
stuff that I love you know and and I you
know wanted to do a Star Wars TV show
like the Mandalorian and pitched it to
them and they were very open to it I
even wrote four episodes before I even
was hired to do it because I was excited
as a fan to see what these stories might
be and see if they were interested in in
doing what what I was interested in
which they were so I'm and now I'm right
I was actually writing this season 2
this morning before I came here and Lion
King has been you know a a very
different experience because here it was
something where you're adhering very
much to a story that people know very
well it's a huge team of people working
towards a theatrical release and a great
cast and there's music and there's you
know visual effects that go into it and
it's a very long slow process to create
this whatever it is hour and a half hour
and 45 minute film while you're
collaborating with hundreds of people so
sometimes I like to do smaller stuff
sometimes bigger but you always have to
have a great story that you want to tell
that's the thing that's the guiding
principle behind all these things
something that with this film the
technology to bring this to life is my
jaw was on the ground watching this in
terms of the technology I've spoken to
some of the people involved in
Mandalorian and they talked about how
you push the boundary with technology
talk a little bit about if you don't
mind yeah
share the technology you did for this
and on Mandalorian sure and you know
like those things that you had to
overcome to bring it to life so um
there's always opportunities with each
new technological brain breakthrough and
Walt Disney by the way started that with
when he first started working with even
Steamboat Willie there was always
technological breakthroughs associated
the underwater sequence of Pinocchio
it's been part of it's been part of the
the game
from the beginning you want to tell
great stories but have new new
techniques right now the big
breakthrough for us was VR but VR is
really built around a game engine in the
case of doing the virtual production for
Lion King we use the Unity engine system
Magno puces a company that helped us
build a multiplayer vr filmmaking game
so that we could take our digital
environments digital animated characters
and actually go in there with the film
crew into the VR space and so the VR was
used for us to visualize and basically
create a template for the shots that
were cut together for the final film and
the mandalorian because we're doing
live-action production we're using we're
using the epic gaming game engine and
using that to do real-time in-camera
visual effects and so if you visited the
set for the mandalorian you would have
seen a completely video wall wrapped
stage and we were in there filming the
characters in the foreground and
oftentimes either blue screen or full
digital versions of set extensions in
the background with parallax because the
positional data of the camera was
informing the backgrounds and so it was
like a translate that had perspective
and so that allowed us to have
environments as long as we could build
them digitally and put enough work into
planning it we could have the game
engine be used for creating effects in a
time frame that allows us to get a TV
season done but all of that requires us
to use the same v-cam techniques in
pre-production on the mandalorian so
that we know exactly what we need to see
and so if you visited the set now as
we're starting to get into season 2 it
looks a lot like the set of Lion King as
we're planning how we're going to shoot
it ahead of time